more reopening team coverage continues
yes it does with one of my favorite
restaurants hofbrau house joe moeller is
live there and joe they obviously closed
down for so long they rely a lot on the
convention center businesses
what's it like now that they're back
open
well it's one of my favorites too i have
to admit uh hop raw house here in las
vegas has been closed for more than a
year throughout the pandemic and they're
not even
open just yet take a live look here
behind me they're just about to actually
let people in
customers our first customers in 15
months they were forced to close through
the pandemic and now they'll be able to
welcome back
100 capacities as you can imagine
employees are excited that was actually
the first customer you just watched
walk through those doors many have been
waiting for this day including the
several employees who work here 80
percent of their business comes from
tourists so they said
it made sense for them to wait now
county restrictions dropped and that
means businesses around the valley can
operate
at 100 capacity if you are vaccinated
you no longer have to wear a mask
in recent months las vegas slowly
returned to normal now business owners
say allowing more customers
means more money tony singer of opera
house las vegas says it is nice to see
the city come back to life
we are very excited you can imagine
after 15 months
close we have around 200 000 guests a
year
and then this is a huge operation and
overnight
the government says we have to shut down
this is a big impact
for us
and like you just heard uh hector
mentioned there don't put those masks
away just yet some businesses can still
ask you to uh
have that mask and require them for for
customers and is still required on
public transportation in places such as
airports now back out here live you're
taking another look
at the seating here inside of opera
house las vegas those are the first
customers back in here in about 15
months
uh there's also live music they brought
that back as well they just opened their
doors here at four i'm gonna have mark
step over here
and show you they're getting ready with
the band back there in the corner so
that's obviously exciting
we did talk to some employees here who
are working here as well and they're
obviously excited to be back here
to the place that they know and they say
it's like a family here so they're
excited to be back
at work they're just excited to have
opera house back open just like you are
a happy guy kirsten i'll send it back to
you